dans notre série cultivons notre jardin
ce petit détour par chaumont sur loire
qui organise autour de son château et
pour la sixième année consécutive un
festival des jardins thème cette année
que d'eau que d'eau pour reprendre
l'expression du toujours regretté mme
hackmann
reportage en ferrain natalie kerris
fleurs des champs et fontaine de bambou
mû par de minces filets d'eau sont
insolites qui suscite le regard toujours
en alerte dans ce jardin baignée de
soleil
un peu plus loin un espace très
construit les plantes entourée d'eau
glisse et s'agitent au bord de la noyade
pas du décor de théâtre c'est pas des
oeuvres d'art c'est vraiment des vrais
jardins et les gens qui viennent
d'ailleurs où il ya plein de gens qui
prennent toujours des notes comme ça
qu'ils écrivent pour piquer les idées on
en attend on a découvert un peu ce thème
et c'est vrai que ils viennent nous voir
l'année d'après avec les photos de ce
qu'ils ont réalisé réussies ou ratées
mais c'est ça qui passe si c'est quelque
chose de très modeste et très proche des
gens mieux l'expérience lieu
d'expérience à portée de tous c'est pas
si compliqué à chaumont-sur-loire tous
les jardins sont l'oeuvre de paysagistes
ou d'architecte bien souvent épaulés par
un sculpteur ou un plasticien qu'il
vienne polar ou pour la botanique
le public a l'air d'aimer ça je 100
mètres carrés de jardin je peux pas en
faire grand chose
c'est beau ils vont pas prendre un
jardin et on en parle un blog qui vont
prendre une micro scène c'est à dire une
association de deux plantes de couleur
quand on est passionné de jardins que
l'on rencontre dans une journée qu'on
rencontre une plan deux trois quatre
plantes
on est heureux il ya aussi les
professionnels toujours à la quête du
petit truc et c'est exotique ça aussi
c'est une fois qu on est plusieurs à
feignies on vient ici pour photographier
ce jardin pour le voir pour donner des
idées à nos étudiants quelques peintres
aussi inspiré par cette nature généreuse
ce potager par exemple fouillis
inextricable de choux courges et des
tomates dont l'artiste isole joliment
ces quelques fleurs